[Music]
in happy accident news submitted by box
of rocks yeah
a nine-year-old accidentally want an
adult ten kilometer race like ran across
the finish line
um yeah like like accidentally winning
that's six miles how do you accidentally
the kid was maybe by the sidelines and
just ran across the finish line yeah
exactly that's exactly have no wow he
entered the race without people knowing
he just started we're in his dog his
lost dog and his dog was running down
these well before I tell you I want to
remind you guys to subscribe if you
haven't
join the JK fan it's really easy just
click that button and a bell you need
the belt it's exactly the belt or else
you're never gonna figure out why the
kid cost the finish line
we're not gonna tell you until you do
out so I'm gonna wait I feel they did it
cool okay so this kid wait there's this
okay he did it he's cynical [ __ ] yeah we
saw you did it yes you did it good job
welcome to the family anyway so this guy
I mean not this guy this kid this nine
year olds from Minnesota his name is
Kade he was actually running a 5k so he
paid it this is good yeah it's your
birthday we love it he hates me no no he
loves you so they're saying that this
day was rainy and miserable but
apparently right when he was supposed to
make a turn to finish the 5k a volunteer
confused him for a 10k runner and told
him to go in to go straight so then he
ended up going in like it was funny too
because he actually are you looking at
everyone like this like [ __ ] was
everyone so tall
yeah so he not only finished the 10k he
finished in first place that's how much
the [ __ ] contestants suck
hehe
finished in 48 minutes and 17 seconds
which is nearly a full minute faster
than the runner-up does it count it does
because they changed his registration
from 5k to Tim Kaine this is the first
time he did a 10k but he has been
running since he was 6 years old but how
old is he 9 how come everyone else suck
so bad no no the mom said that he was
probably like just so like anxious to
finish already because he's like what he
was probably thinking like why is this
taking so long like I'm trying to finish
already he didn't know he was he's like
I'm on a conveyor belt so he ended up
winning and he got first place and
everyone was just like what that's
amazing it's incredible but ok well
before the mom found out because she was
waiting for him at the finish line and
when he never showed up she started
freaking out and like even got like the
cops looking for him the copters all
looking for finish so then it turns out
that there was someone oh this is when
he actually won exhausted so then
someone like this at the end of the 5k
line where the mom was because she sent
his grandma to go look for him somewhere
along the actual marathon whatever it is
yes trail and um that's when the gun was
like I don't know he's not here and then
someone nearby was like hey there's this
kid in the 10k he's doing really good
and that's when they found out that he
was running the 10k Oh could it be so
they're saying that 225 people competed
in various event not just as various
events the average age for the 10k
runners was 38 and for the 5k runners
was 35 oh wow I would be pissed off the
10k like consisted of like uphill and
downhill but then the 5k was just like
Nene I'd be like I'd be [ __ ] pissed
win it it's not the same trail that we
ran I'm gonna be penny yeah plus she was
born my [ __ ] the year 2010 [ __ ] this
kids right I would quit running if that
[ __ ] kid won
yeah me too and I'm all like I'm gonna
say my moving my legs after you know I
mean if he's been running since 6 he
must have known you think my boy were
you running yeah it's like Oh would you
have stopped though yeah I've been like
I did my five [ __ ] this and I would I
woulda just kept going yeah well I'm
gonna win this big this is one of those
kids who doesn't have video games so he
doesn't know what fun real fun is and
he's like this is fun to me
I felt her fellow just sad go sad
melancholy I've only felt that once in
my life and I've never could understand
how people love running until I felt
that moment and I was like whoa this is
dope but I never did it again because
it's painful to get there but then it
gets addicting and then I recently felt
it again when I was doing a kickboxing
class and I was like I got like my
second win and I'm like whoa this is so
fun oh my god I could keep going for
hours it's pretty cool I mean everything
is that drinking wine hanging out you
could wine and wine is high wine and run
there's really thanks I've heard of like
like a Vegas joke exposing your face I
judge those people harshly by my job to
get to the runner's high though it's a
lot of pain so with the wine you just
it's very relaxed and they got it in a
glutton wine it goes from good to better
I mean ridiculous no be like Nikki's to
go wine glass that's true how did those
wine events happen do they drink first
and then they run or do they have like a
sippy cup like they're like quick or do
they have those helmets with the
toothpaste are
I've never seen someone do that with
wine that's inventive yeah see look even
Disney does it yeah Disney wine and dine
half marathon weekend wine and dine
[Music]
buffet and run run the wicked way
eat a buffet and run the 10k what if
it's at the end
I'm hoping it's at the end it's not like
a Oh like it's three day event and then
in the last days the run or something
races for wine lovers so they're running
with a glass of wine
these people are absurd it can't be
mixed because I'm just imagining like
you know the water stations instead of
that it's just [ __ ] glasses of wine
and you just [ __ ] game yeah that
sounds fun hey you are fun my friend
that sounds all of the people running or
crashing into each other just no one's
running straight to begin with a
drinking and running competition sounds
amazing
yeah it's like the baseball play you
know you put the baseball like that you
run around and then you punch him I'm
sold now yeah dude you should do it oh
my there's a really big event where you
smoke weed and you do jujitsu oh yeah
just slow nobody how you see something
most creative moves ever really yeah
they do they're spinning on their badges
and all kinds of crazy [ __ ] Wow just the
slowest trick you know like you could
break everything and you'll be all right
yeah everybody's just like super
creative and they're just moving around
it's a really big event it's not like
they're all underwater funny
do you like smoke while you're doing it
yeah smoke and immediately immediately
go up no like we're in the middle of it
someone has like a joint break do be
like Joe and then they run over and end
our life and if they [ __ ] keep going
gets you every time
yeah that's creative I guess you just
pick random two things and just put them
together it's like this plus alcohol
this plus weed I've heard of like weed
and yoga that makes them see that kind
of peaceful those fit well those are two
puzzle pieces that fit really good the
other ones people randomly eat and
running what
never happened next steroids in ballet
time you need some kinda hits you right
away right hey you don't know the
physical toll that ballet it takes on a
person it's hard I know that's I'm
saying or like drinking and swimming
that's bad you'll drown anything drugs
in swimming I wouldn't condone no
drinking at the beach in swimming school
I like smoking weed and drag racing just
something fast with weed oh [ __ ] so this
is it just like mid like it's not that
fast I'm shooting and drinking would be
sick
they're shooting yeah well no you drink
up in the thing and then you jump all
you can even that helmet all the gliding
there was just hang gliding when you
have the thing right yeah so there was
this guy who was on his instructor and I
guess he got like sick so he's like hang
gliding luckily it was going in the
direction of the window so he's like
what the instructors in the front that's
a different sport
I like monsters and snowboarding yeah by
the b-two and dirt biking and
skateboarding yep monsters and sitting
there yeah I experienced uh ketamine
with snowboarding once is that fun what
does that do it's called a special cage
like a chunk Eliza watch Nicholas it's
like an animal tranquilizer
Jesus it makes you kinda numb well makes
you numb and it makes you kind of
disoriented and all that but it makes
you say hello to you right so so you're
so floaty I we me and my friend thought
it would be a good idea to do it because
it's like snowboarding already feels
like you're floating but then you kind
of lose the power in your body and
joints and stuff yeah so like as we're
we're not controlling everything at the
right time so both of us we're all
recarved like we're just we carve and it
just stops and then we start falling and
rolling so both of us were just rolling
down the [ __ ]
he'll and we're like this is not a good
idea dude how many times did you do it
twice
make sure cuz at top we got down there
we're like I don't remember if it's
because you don't tranquilizer on you
watch TV you see a perfectly good
gazelle right in the goal that's
basically what happened
what's do to each other that's exactly
what happened when you see two guys
going down and they're like carving like
this and then all of a sudden it's yeah
and we're just sitting there we're like
oh I can't [ __ ] get up is it funny at
least what is that those that was back
then man that was over 15 years ago
humans must have gone so bored with just
everything it's like let's do some crazy
stuff well the other animals are just
trying to survive like how can we do
something just crazy like snowboarding's
not crazy enough I have to do it like
with I don't know why out of all the
drugs I did that but that's like rugby
or cricket right that's some boring ass
[ __ ] that humans did cuz we're bored
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]